[Music]
so with all of the asian hate incidents
hey
bully
no no we're saying yes about something
he's like yes catching criminals so with
all the attacks in the elderly um
thank you everyone for your comments
about it on all these different
platforms it doesn't do anything but
there are people out there who are
awareness and stuff
there's people out there who are
creating programs to help
fight back and help protect our elderly
ron is absolutely one of them thank you
so much
ron's got a program that helps teach
elders to take care of themselves and
defend against possible attackers
what's that been like man
it's been really awesome i've never
really jumped into like non-profit type
of stuff um like i've been just helping
people through martial arts one-on-one
and then social media but uh
a random person reached out and uh they
started this thing called seniors fight
back and they wanted me to jump in they
wanted to do self-defense programs for
the elderly they're like we have no idea
what that looks like but we think you
would be helpful and i was like heck
yeah and then so i jumped in and nine
months later
we've taught over 2 000 live students
wow that's a lot yeah dude it's been
freaking nuts that's so cool it's just
been a one-year anniversary wow 3 000
yeah we've given out over 5000 pepper
sprays and sirens that's awesome yeah
and then randomly so uh randomly we got
awarded the nonprofit of the year for
the 47th district in the state of
sacramento so we got to go to sacramento
and receive some award thingy that's
it's cool man yeah it's been uh it's
been it's been really cool
but uh yeah we show up and like some of
our events have like over 200 like
seniors show up and we're just going
there and they're like they're coming in
and then like we go over like posture
and like sending the proper message out
to not look like a target like most of
the training is invasive non-contact
it's just three it's that's what i was
thinking too because if they're old
they're not going to be able to fight a
20 year old man so it's like what what
do you teach them so the three most
effective things for self-defense don't
require touching them at all it's
situational awareness
you look at the media most of people
getting attacked they're just minding a
little business and they're completely
unaware of what's going on around me
it's just being asian
driving walking sitting duck feeding
raising newspaper playing chess
they don't have the they don't have the
spider senses
because like when you grow up in certain
places like you just know you just feel
it you're just like
that [ __ ] right there but
nowadays everybody's oblivious to
everything people are on their cell
phones like even driving their oblivious
to that they're in somebody else's lane
you know like dude you wouldn't believe
the accidents i see in a day yeah the
people at the crosswalk you'll see like
five people all on their phones walking
across the crosswalk almost getting hit
they don't even look left and right
because if you have one of those you
know those crazy people that like uh
just run red lights or something [ __ ]
dude if they if some guy flew down they
would just knock yeah awesome i've seen
a girl get hit with a car at 45 miles an
hour and they she flew like 25 yards it
was the craziest thing and she was she
on her phone the whole time in the air
she's still watching tick tock
she zoomed in she was watching jk news
[Laughter]
i was in downtown and that that exact
thing happened the light was green
lady like you would assume that she
would stop she didn't even look up
she just started walking and i was like
what the [ __ ] and she looked up at me
like i'm wrong and i'm like that's a
[ __ ] green light you crazy son of a
[ __ ] but on that same day though there
were two guys that merged into my lane
and i look over and they're on their
phone merging and i'm like who the [ __ ]
merges while they look on their phone
everybody nowadays just because they
have the right away means that everybody
should stop because that's the law right
but obviously how often does that not
happen a lot so very tough good for
phones though so these uh the seniors
that come are they like where do you
teach is it like you know at a park or
yeah so we'll do um our first one is at
the asian garden mall so that was like
the heart of uh the heart of little
saigon in orange county it's like where
that's like a historical landmark it was
sick we had 200 seniors we taught them
all this stuff so situational awareness
um body language the message that we
send out to the world and then the
message that the people are sending out
to us so like the way the way i stand
right like sends how to mention am i
weak am i tired of my frail right or am
i scary am i crazy you know and then i
can't wait to see a little grandma do
that oh dude
there's footage i have videos of it dude
i have i have little grandmas it's kind
of tony robbins but i'll have grandmas
and grandpas i'll say pretend you have a
superman cape on you know have your chin
up have your arms out your chest i want
you to stomp around for 10 seconds and
they'll do it you can imagine like 200
people just stomping around you have
them like like embody that energy so
they know how to like do this
yeah yeah yeah give him a hand give him
a hand dude that's so embarrassing when
you did it no matter who cares we don't
know these people you know it's just a
little being silly is that but how did
you feel weak no you made me feel crazy
you know but if a predator is going to
decide between a person that walks like
this the person that walks like this who
are they going to attack first you know
so these are all deterrents you know so
and then body language you know somebody
walks to you like this in a threatening
manner they're sending a message like
hey i probably mean harm but if they
walk to you like this you know usually
they usually they they probably mean
less harm you know and then that's body
and then voice we have that the people
say six feet of space but for me that's
too close like there's not a whole lot
of reaction time for six feet so i say
12 feet two car spaces if someone's
within two car spaces of you then you
should probably be aware of their
existence and and dictate whether
they're going to be threatening or not
you know if they get too close then you
use your voice stop use your hand and go
back to r3 situational awareness you
know distance body language voice and
those are the three most effective
things for self-defense so practical man
yeah very practical honestly is even
without even getting into an altercation
a lot of them could even even two dudes
at a bar
you know like i don't want to fight or
whatever and then you cause a scene yeah
you ever someone gets hot someone gets
crazy in a bar fight they start acting
crazy like what you're gonna find me you
wanna mess with me you start freaking
like putting fecal matter on you
does that guy want to fight you anymore
you know no i said oh you're crazy man
that's that you just said
someone fight me we actually give we're
selling seniors fight back poopy bags so
if everybody wants to get mad you take
it out and you smear it across your
chest
intimidation when uh when you were
trying to
like get the word out to seniors to come
to this thing how what's the best way to
do that how do you like get them to know
that this exists
funny enough you would think it's social
media it's not it's not yeah that's not
registering my mind we'll have like four
people register online for the classes
and then 200 people will show up um it's
it's newspapers it's local radio it's um
the the local community organizers right
and so we we've gone to like senior
communities um senior what is it called
senior homes yeah retirement homes
retirement homes huge we went to l.a
right across from the uh
what's that grand central market yeah
yeah yeah right across there's a there's
a senior living center oh there is and
they don't even know yeah there's over
like on grand avenue on that side yeah
right now next to that you know that
trolley that goes to like oh the
upstairs to somewhere
um in the back right there there's a
senior living community and there's like
400 people that were so freaking cool
they all showed up we did waves of
classes for all these seniors and then
we we taught them all and um they were
all so grateful and helpful and like
even had people in freaking walkers they
would get off their walker and then like
clinch somebody
um
you'd be surprised how strong some of
these seniors are like some of them hit
hit hard like we we don't teach punches
because two it takes too much precision
and it's so easy to break your hands you
know so we teach them clinching we
minimize the distance
after
if you're aware they exist and you've
read their body language and they got
too close and yelled stop and they're
still coming at you
they want to hurt you no matter what you
want all these dead reds and they still
want to hurt you then we have to get
physical so we teach them three things
once it gets physical because now your
life is on the line physically we teach
them a clinch
to minimize the range uh because right
here is dangerous here's where they're
most effective right so if i minimize it
can they still hit us and hurt us yeah
but they're less effective right so it's
unless they're two evils and then from
there if they're still fighting us then
we go for elbows and knees um whether it
lands or not doesn't matter it's
alarming someone does this right in
front of you it's like oh snap like they
know what they're doing or oh snap to
freaking hurt like elbows hurt knees
hurt and like we're not teaching a super
perfect technique we're literally thumb
down throwing your chest turn yeah
that's pretty good techniques
that's pretty good that guy's a pro
though yeah
um
so that that that wards them away and
it's cool to see because that gives them
confidence like oh my gosh i didn't know
i could hit this hard and so some of you
get excited they're going
i got i got neat in the nuts on the
first event
dude some lady went nuts she missed the
pad it went right to my nuts and i was
like
i was like oh and they recorded the
whole thing and then i'm so sorry it's
like no you did what you're supposed to
do good job
you know and so um that's still
effective very very effective you don't
even have to hit them and so but that's
worst case scenario these predators
they're weak look at the media when they
hit or attack or strike somebody they're
not standing there like like look what i
just did they run away yeah right right
so
they don't want a crowd and the motive
is just to get more eyes to the scene
yell scream yeah you get yeah scream
yell i even tell them yo banana yell
freaking yell freaking pokey taco it
doesn't matter you know just get
attention towards you um so they're less
likely because they don't want an
audience they want to hit and run so the
more eyes you bring to the situation the
less likely they are to move forward
what's something that you've learned
from like doing this i've learned
what's which which is funny is uh i
guess not funny um peculiar and
interesting is outside of the
self-defense i found the most benefit is
uh discovering that the elderly
community feel very unsupported and
alone um the fact that um we've been
able to to create events and community
events and shows like hey and i tell
them at every workshop i was like we
just want to let you know that us we
want to thank the city or the
organization or whatever or we want to
thank you know senator blah blah blah um
that we are here for you we support you
and we love you um and that alone you
see they're like
like you can read it you could read the
crowd you know but what if they deserve
it
yeah what's your take on that someone
might look at my dad i'm like oh look at
that old guy right i gotta take care of
him whatever am i not you don't know him
you smell like mothballs
this guy this guy's annoying he's
[ __ ] judging me all day and [ __ ]
trying to give me [ __ ] advice on
things no
so annoying oh we'll get dude some
workshops will get an expert like
someone that's done like uh wushua
xiaolin for like freaking 20 years like
and do you want to start teaching the
class yeah they're like well yeah and
then um yeah it's it will have people on
social media like commenting on the
videos it's like that wouldn't work if i
really wanted to attack that old lady i
would oh my god good for you yeah good
job [ __ ] tough guy
get me in a clutch watch what happens
what kind of weird competition is that i
got a funny question since we're dealing
with this generation of asian elders
does racial profiling come into play at
all
uh as far as
as far as avoiding doing it or
encouraging it oh safety for safety it
works across the board
self-defense is self-defense we just
picked we picked the thing that we want
to relate to the most right like if you
want to help the world you can't help
everybody can't help everything you know
if you're a scientist maybe you want to
invent the cure for for cancer or aids
you know for me it was martial arts so
how can i use martial arts and you know
as i get older i get closer to my roots
and so i was like cool i'm asian let's
help an asian community that i'm close
to um i respect the elderly greatly and
i know martial arts bam seniors fight
back i can relate to that i i can get
behind that because right now there
isn't a bunch of footage of like why
grandma's getting punched on the street
so then i have white grandma's coming
you know they're showing up and getting
help yeah they're trying to gentrify
that [ __ ] too god damn it we try to take
away our limelight
you can't let us have this yeah come on
dude
why don't you go to the elks lodge and
get the train in over there
knights of columbus
brad johnson okay what am my one of my
cop friends like uh explain it to me
pretty cool where it's like i think to
the outside world sometimes it seems
like it's racial profiling but what it
really is is
identifying the unusual thing so for
example if you see um
like just as crazy as it is to see like
let's say
a random like group of three black guys
in monterey park
that's alarming i need to pay attention
and see what's going on
same thing as if we saw like three asian
dudes in all black neighborhood that's
weird too you know so i think like for
them um what's really important to like
prevent crime or to like keep track of
what's going on is if there is an
unusual thing
you have to pay attention to it right
yeah like if there's a pimp
with five girls in a bikini
in the middle of december yeah and
they're not
in inglewood
you're like what's going on here yeah
something's a little off they're not an
eagle
like why aren't you in front of the hong
kong supermarket they're at big bear
if i'm in a chinese restaurant i see
somebody eating a slice of pizza i'm
going to notice that person regardless
of race i'm like you know that whatever
person they're eating pizza in the
chinese
sell that here is that orange chicken
pizza is this a simulation yeah but i
like what you said about if anyone
enters your 12 foot space
you have to acknowledge your existence
you have to be aware of the surroundings
of course you know and i and i learned i
learned that from doing security
remember when i we talked about like oh
yeah every time i walk into the room i'm
kind of aware of just general landmarks
like things that can be used as weapons
and then general people and things in
the vicinity so that way i can prepare
myself in the event that
even when you take when you take a
driving test what are you supposed to do
you're supposed to look at all your
windows every not every nobody does it
anymore nobody you're supposed to look
at all your constantly look at mirrors
mirrors yeah dude doing that alone
prevents accidents so much but we don't
instead we just look at our cell phones
and drive and we we freaking we'd record
a story where we sing a song yeah as we
drive you know we do it dance that's way
more fun we get mad followers
now i'm going to light my back seat on
fire as i drive
follow that
algorithm though
it's all about the hashtags
[Music]
you